[Music]
grappa is an italian brandy
traditionally an after-dinner drink it's
made from pumice
what's left of grapes after they've been
pressed to make wine
distilleries ferment the pumice to
convert the sugars into alcohol
then distill it to transform the alcohol
and other compounds
into grappa
traditional grappa is colorless it can
also be aged in wooden barrels to
produce different varieties
with a specific color taste and aroma
you can't make grappa without someone
first making wine
because wine winemaking leftovers are
the sole ingredient
in italy the wine harvest begins in late
summer or early fall
depending on the weather and region of
the country
the harvested grapes go directly from
the vineyard to the winery
there the first machine pulls them off
the stalks
which are later composted into
fertilizer for farms and nurseries
the de-stocked grapes enter a
cylindrical press
they're crushed against the walls with
an airbag-like device
to extract the juice and pulp for making
wine
what's left behind in the press once the
juice and pulp drain out
are the skins seeds some residual juice
and palm this is called pumice
the winery sells it to distilleries that
produce grappa
this small artisanal distillery produces
premium quality grappa
by using only pumice from grapes pressed
that very same day
the pumice goes into temperature
controlled fermentation tanks
as soon as it arrives
large industrial distilleries operate
differently
typically warehousing palmas prior to
processing
sometimes for months this delay produces
high levels of potentially toxic
methanol
which the distillery then has to remove
using an additional procedure
the distillers monitor ph and alcohol
levels to determine when the conversion
of sugars to alcohol is complete
the process takes from three days to a
week
depending on the variety of grape and
other factors
such as the outdoor temperature
when the pumice is ready they transfer
it to wood clad copper stills
the heat distills with steam bringing
the pumice to the boiling point
which transforms the alcohol and other
compounds into steam
this alcohol steam inside the still
rises to the top
and exits through a side hole it travels
through copper pipes and other equipment
ultimately to a condensation system
which cools the steam back to liquid
this liquid is grappa as it exits
distillation
the master distiller meticulously
monitors the temperature and alcohol
level
she discards the initial and final flows
capturing only the perfectly pure
midflow
referred to as the heart of the grappa
its alcohol level at this point is 70 to
77
[Music]
certain varieties now go to the cellar
into small wooden barrels to age
over time both the grappa and the wooden
barrels exchange compounds
which influence taste aroma and color
for example a barrel made of cherry wood
will produce different characteristics
than one made of oak
the distilleries experts analyze and
taste samples following distillation
and throughout the aging period
depending on the variety
this can range from just one year to
more than 20 years
whether the grappa is aged or not prior
to bottling
they filter and dilute it with
demineralized water
this lowers the alcohol content from an
average of 77
after distillation to the target level
of 41 to 50
[Music]
they seal the bottles with stoppers made
of food safe synthetic materials
rather than traditional corks natural
cork contains certain organic compounds
which can alter the flavor aroma and
color of the grappa
[Music]
they seal the stopper with shrink wrap
plastic
an unbroken seal assures the buyer that
the bottle has not been previously
opened
then the bottles pass through a labeling
station
the grappa is ready to be poured as an
after dinner drink
or enjoy it on its own as the italians
say
[Music]
salute